in the early 1960s a new kind of
beverage took the stage it wasn't a new
shape or color or flavor no this was
diet soda and it was awesome with fewer
calories and less sugar diet soda
promised to be a healthier alternative
to regular soda
but like most promises in life that
sound too good to be true it probably is
can you tell the difference between a
class of regular and diet soda turns out
neither can your body and that's where
the trouble starts until recently
everything we ate contains some amount
of calories when we ate something sweet
for example the brain sent signals to
our pancreas which started producing
insulin that stored the sugar molecules
in our cells for energy so when we drink
diet soda
the sweetness tricks our body into
thinking it's real sugar but when those
energy pack calories don't arrive the
insulin has nothing to store scientists
think that repeatedly tricking our body
this way could explain why study after
study keeps finding the same things that
drinking diet soda is associated with
metabolic syndrome metabolic syndrome is
a mix of conditions that includes
increased blood pressure high blood
sugar and weight gain which can increase
the risk of diabetes heart disease and
stroke in fact one study found that diet
soda drinkers had a higher risk of
stroke and dementia than regular soda
drinkers and for another eight year long
study between 1979 and 1988 participants
who started out at a normal weight and
drank an average of 21 diet beverages a
week face doubled the risk of becoming
overweight or obese by the end of the
study compared to people who voided diet
beverages completely and while drinking
diet soda with a meal may sound like a
tasty calorie free alternative to plain
water the growing body of research is
starting to find that this may be the
worst time to drink it because the fake
calories in the diet soda could
ultimately disrupt how many of the real
calories
metabolise potentially leaving excess
calories behind that we then store as
fat another issue could be the fact that
artificial sweeteners and diet sodas can
be tens to hundreds of times sweeter
than sugar so when we taste it our
brains anticipate more calories than
will be given it's like when you go to a
party expecting loads of food and you
end up with a handful of veggies and
vegan cheese you're left unsatisfied and
angry in the same way
artificial sweeteners can leave our
brains wanting more which studies have
shown leads to increased appetite and
potential weight gain and fruit flies
mice and humans so if the reason you're
drinking diet soda is to drop a few
pounds maybe just stick to water got any
friends obsessed with diet soda share
this video with them and thanks for
watching